herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie meine heutigen gäste nehmen
nicht alles so ernst sondern mischen mit
bissiger satire unsere festgefahrene
meinungen auf bei mir sitzen party
basler und peter schneider schön dass
sie da sind
ich verrate schon mal so viel patina
fleiß ganz vernarrt in johanna spyri
heidi peter schneider dagegen steht er
auf enid blytons fünf freunde
ob sie das ernst meinen werden wir
später noch sehen
ja frau basler sie haben gerade den
salzburger stier gewonnen das ist der
wichtigste preis für kleinkunst im
deutschsprachigen raum und einem
breiteren publikum sind sie vor allem
auch bekannt als instanz protokollerin
in der arena sie selber bezahlen sich ja
als besserwisserin was wissen sie denn
genau besser besserwisserin hat ja
nichts damit zu tun dass man wirklich
etwas besser weiß da ist ja auch schon
immer nur dieses vermeintliche besser
wissen dabei und impliziert ich bin
gelernte und habe auch praktiziert als
lehrerin und das ist einfach ein beruf
dann das besser wissen und diesen beruf
lieben sie auch aus wenn ich ihn dann
protokollerin sind nein da bin ich ja
nur reaktiv aber natürlich kann ich am
schluss diesem schlusspunkt setzen und
man kann mir dann nicht mehr
widersprechen
das kommt mir natürlich entgegen das
besser wissen gehört ja auch bei ihnen
so ein bisschen dazu herr schneider sie
sind ein sehr bekannter satiriker in der
schweiz und wie man munkelt der
bestbezahlte kolumnist der schweiz eine
ihrer kolleginnen
leser fragen im tages anzeiger und im
bund da senden leute ihnen fragen ein
und packt man hat den eindruck sie sind
experte für alles die leute fragen was
sie von homosexualität halten ob
einzelkinder ein problem sind und wie
sie es mit der religion so haben sind
sie in experte für alles ja man muss
sich halt überlegen was da expertise
eigentlich ist es gibt sie die eine
expertise dass man sich speziell in
irgendeinem gebiet auskennt zum paar
gebiete habe ich auch wo ich nicht
besonders aus kenne aber
diese taci kolumnen expertise ist ja
mehr die menge negativer also es ist
eher eine anti expertise dass man sagt
was immer das ist so ist es sicher nicht
so nehmen wir jetzt gleich spiel
homosexualität homosexualität ist weder
wieder natürlich aber sie ist auch nicht
natürlich sondern sie ist ein
kulturelles produkt zum beispiel und
dafür muss man jetzt keine empirischen
studien in soziologie der homosexualität
gemacht haben das kann man sicher schon
mal so sagen und insofern bin ich ihren
anti experte sie haben in ihrem buch
nichts genaueres weiß man in dem die
kolumbien versammelt sind am anfang ja
auch sie haben nicht auf alles eine
antwort aber keine antwort wäre ja nicht
gedruckt ja das immer leute dass das
problem also ich würde gerne mal für
schweigen bezahlt sie werden schon für
die kolumbien sehr gut bezahlt da kann
man schweigen gefallen also ich glaube
das habe ich mal irgendwie in einem
anflug von größenwahn gesagt also so
wahnsinnig ist das jetzt mal auch wieder
nicht dass die leute dann ich meinen das
sei gut 700 ja das ist nicht beste zeit
in taucha bietet mit frau basler wenn
ihr noch mal zum besser wissen oder zum
expertentum zurückkommen sie haben mal
in einem interview gesagt denken sei
ihre lieblingsbeschäftigung
da muss man ja dann auch was besser
wissen oder und denken und besserwissen
auch das hat mal genuin überhaupt nichts
miteinander zu tun
aber man kann versuchen durch denken
wissen zu generieren aber dazu muss man
natürlich auch noch ein bisschen lesen
oder sich weiterbilden
das denken an eine nützliche noch nicht
aber das denken hilft sicher die
synapsen richtig zu verknüpfen so dass
man wieder auf wissen auch zurückgreifen
kann im richtigen moment und denken
meine lieblings geschäft das ist das
liegt auch an meiner körperlichen
faulheit also ich bin sehr träge also
physikalisch träger und das denken das
flugzeug auch physikalisch nicht nur
physisch
das trägheitsmoment ja beide
besserwisserisch veranlagt das trifft
sich ja auch gut doppelt hat natürlich
das sage ich auch nicht aus
psychoanalytikerin sondern als
besserwisserin nein und das denken
braucht auch energie aber es braucht
keinen physischen aufwand habe das
denken eigentlich eine richtung kommen
an ihn denken voran denken ist ja nicht
theologisch also denn nein aber manche
naja aber man kommt negativ voran das
ist das was ich mit der anti expertise
meinte also man bleibt offen für neues
aber man weiß gleichzeitig welchen
kwakman nicht mehr durch denken muss
also eben zum beispiel bleiben wir jetzt
beim home beispiel homosexualität man
muss nicht mehr in brehms tierleben
nachgucken ob es nicht vielleicht doch
natürlich ist weil auch die tauben und
die für - wenn man einmal gemerkt hat
das ist einfach ein denk fehlschluss
homosexualität so rehabilitieren zu
wollen dass man sagt es kommt eben auch
beim pinguin vor sein das muss man
anders machen und wenn man das mal
gedacht hat dann weiß man wohin nicht
mehr zurück aber alles andere bleibt
offen
oft verfällt man ja aber immer wieder in
ähnliche denkmuster das ist ja die
gefahr dass man was man schon mal
gedacht hat immer immer wieder denken
dass ich das verfestigt
das habe ich ehrlich gesagt weniger weil
alles alte was ich schon mal gedacht
habt eine tendenziell eher auf den keks
weil es langweilig sonst langweilig aber
das wäre ja dann gingen wir sprechen
dass das was man gedacht habe damals
gedacht ist und abgehakt weil sie hätten
ja dann langweilig also denken sie
irgendwann das gegenteil nicht das
gegenteil nein sondern ich versuchen
anderen zugang also dieses dieses
starken thesen also eine starke these
löst die andere starke these ab und das
finde ich einen blödsinnigen denkt
vortritt aber es hat schon so was von
den ökonomischen prinzip dass man sich
denkt auf manchen spuren muss ich jetzt
nicht mehr denkend wandeln aber es gibt
jetzt eben das sind ausschlussverfahren
es gibt nichts wo man sagt das habe ich
mal so toll gedacht das muss ich jetzt
immer wieder weiter in diesem stil
denken das finde ich es auch eine
gewisse altersweisheit wenn man
irgendwann so viele gedacht hat kann man
kann man es dann irgendwann auch sein
lassen und was anderes denken ehrlich
gesagt junge frau auch schon altersweise
das war ich aber schon mit zwölf aber es
ist ja auch ein philosophisch
wissenschaftlicher ansatz eigentlich nur
dass man das dass man resultat offen ist
und irgendwo auf den schultern von
giganten auch mal aufbaut weil gewisse
dinge schon gedacht oder zumindest noch
nicht falsifiziert sind und dann kann
man nun mal weiter denn da ist ja auch
was interessant ist dieses stehen quasi
auf den schultern des riesen und das
weiterdenken
da gibt es ja die idee von von georges
theiler der gesagt hat denken macht
traurig weil wir dauernd feststellen
alles was wir uns ausdenken wurde
eigentlich schon mal gedacht und es gibt
wenig originalität im denken machtdenken
irgendwie auch traurig ich habe das
immer affirmativ zitiert aber ich glaube
das nicht ich finde denken macht denken
macht schreit das klingt wie ein blöder
slogan aber es macht spaß also ich
glaube es ist eher was das würde ich
jetzt so nicht einfach unterschreiben
denkt macht lebendig also dass auch das
traurige generiert sich ja oft aus dem
denken wenn man etwas trauriges denkt
und sich in dieses man denkt sich ja
auch in eine gefühlswelt hinein
emotionen sind ja auch einfach
schlussendlich nur
prozesse die dem denken nicht gleich
kommen die im hirn irgendwo sich
abspielen und es kann spaß bringen es
kann aber sich auch traurigkeit
befördern das denke ich ich werde er
sein
es erhebt ein immer so etwas über die
traurigkeit also weil das das einzige
was man hat wo man wenn man irgendwie
über das unmittelbare eben zum beispiel
das traurige noch so etwas so mit dem
kopf sich darüber erheben kann auch wenn
es manchmal nur wenig ist sich mit dem
kopf über etwas das gefühl haben man
wird krüger oder einfach für sich etwas
herausfinden und dann weiter gehen
können weil sie habe ich natürlich jetzt
mehr mit dem erheben so über die
wasserlinie gerade so dass man noch ein
bisschen luft krieg also es hat nicht
sehr erhebendes aber das würde dann aber
heißen dass 3d tv tommy ist also das
eine sei das denken und das andere das
fühlen
nur das würde ich nicht nein das geht 11
zu anderen wirklich sagen aber es nimmt
dem wenn man wenn man dabei eben auch
noch denkt nimmt dem ganzen so dieser
unmittelbare kraft sowie das was mit dem
humor zu schreibt also da würde ich
sogar sagen dass denken finde ich da
wichtiger als humor weil humor hat doch
schnell sowas bräsige humoristisches ja
ich bin nicht so ein humor freund da
sprechen wir nachher gleich noch darüber
denken und humor ich werde kurz noch
gerne bei der frage bleiben was denken
eigentlich und ich habe jetzt so ein
bisschen den eindruck frau basel hat sie
auch kein angesprochen als
psychoanalytiker der sie auch sind also
inwiefern kann man eigentlich überhaupt
denken ohne dauernd sozusagen den
untergrund der emotionen mitlaufen zu
lassen sind überhaupt in der lage
wirklich nur zu denken oder ist diese
frage schon irgendwie verkehrt ich
glaube die frage ist und verkehrt also
wenn man einmal auf dieser linie von von
von von gegensätzlichen dings ist dann
muss man sich eben überlegen wie kommt
das dann wieder zusammen
und es muss gar nicht zusammen kommt das
von anfang an eben eben eben zusammen
also ist es auch gar nicht auseinander
genommen es ist nicht eine ausnahme
genommen wären also dass in der
feministischen theorie ist es ja mit dem
body went wieder verstärkt gegen diesen
thematischen dualismus in anschlag
gebracht worden und dass das ist das
nicht mein mann denkt auch nicht mit dem
gehirn soll man denkt eben mit dem
ganzen körper und mit allem drum und
dran sprechen gebe ihr kerngeschäft oder
eines ihrer kerngeschäfte die satire und
man kann sich ja fragen wie sie
eigentlich zu ihren paten kommen ich
habe mich zum beispiel überlegt denken
sie sich die pflanzen eigentlich aus
oder fallen ihnen die pflanzen ein
ist das ein unterschied
also ich kann mich stellen irgendwie vor
setzt man sich da hin und denkt sich
eine zweite aus oder ist das so man geht
durch den wald am einkaufen und
plötzlich macht es klick bei das ist ja
denken was zurückkommen einfälle sind ja
auch einfach gedanken die vielleicht
unerwartet kommen aber sie sind auch
gedanken und dann ist ja die frage
arbeitet man noch weiter dran oder ist
es eben der der erste gedanke der da der
beste ist und da kann man sich auch
wieder fragen ist das dann wie beim
wutbürger manchmal ist der erste gedanke
der beste und ja herr schneider sie
machen ja diese presseschau also da
arbeiten sie ja oft auch mit mit dem
quasi weiter weiteren fragen wenn sie
eine schlagzeile lesen und und die
irgendwie verdrehen auch mit wortspiel
oder mit einer doppel deutung oder
anderen bedeutung aufladen und
verknüpfungen machen dies ist vielleicht
ganz kurz und das erläutern die
radiosendung aus österreich 33 janeiro
wo eben verschiedene schlag sein die
nichts miteinander zu tun aber
eigentlich verknüpft werden und das ist
ja was ähnliches wie ich mache zum
beispiel bei der arena dass ich versuche
die verschiedenen voten miteinander zu
verknüpfen und vielleicht umzudeuten und
und anders zu verstehen
und das passiert einem jahr dann weil
man eben diese schlagzeile diese noten
bekommt also das ist ja
medizin stück weit darauf dass ich
natürlich ist beides ein stück weit
denken aber wenn es einem einfallen muss
dann ist man sozusagen abhängig vom der
gunst der stunde und es kann passieren
dass einem nichts einfällt wenn man sich
ausdenken kann naja dann ist es eine
fleißarbeit wahrscheinlich ist es ja
beides aber ich glaube es ist viel man
braucht eine routine also presseschau
ist eine sehr routinierte sache weil das
onkel ist immer dasselbe man nimmt
irgend etwas gedrucktes inzwischen auch
schon aus twitter und so aber es hat
sozusagen eine textvorlage die verknüpft
und verdreht mann und das ganze hat noch
den vorteil ist es wirklich rein
gesprochene sache also es geht zum einen
ohr rein bleibt vielleicht ein bisschen
drin und geht wieder raus also man muss
nicht in dem sinne dass island jetzt an
an der formulierung wie wenn man etwas
auf einer länge von 1000 zeichen zum
beispiel auf den punkt bringen muss das
ist einfach munteres munteres verknüpfen
und dann gibt es natürlich sachen die da
muss man dann vielleicht manchmal länger
dran denken zb stimmt die pointe oder
geht sie zugunsten des guten carlos auf
kosten der falschen oder stimmt die
innere logik nicht die sachen wo man
dann viel dran rum gedacht hat werden
vielleicht sachlich gut aber nicht um
ein los besser oder lustiger und am
schönsten ist wenn eben der alberne
einfall sich grad mit der mit der
inneren richtigen logik verknüpft und
dann ist einfach cool
sie haben ja von sich design eine
prokrastination also eine aufschieben
eine person die eigentlich immer alles
wo sich hin schiebt insofern könnte man
sagen sie brauchen dann aber schon das
lampenfieber den druck um überhaupt
tätig zu werden
ja ich hab das ja zu meinem beruf
gemacht diese prokrastination ich bin ja
vor allem als instant protokollantin
unterwegs nicht nur in der arena sondern
auch an tagungen und kongressen
konferenzen wo ich dann auch ein
bisschen länger sprechen darf am schluss
aus nur zwei minuten und dort habe ich
dann auch nicht mehr die zeit wirklich
das nochmals zu überdenken da muss ich
mich darauf verlassen dass das
einigermaßen gut kommt und was mir da
sicher hilft ich bin ja slam poet
inhaber so gelernt auf der bühne zu
performen und das performance macht die
halbe miete natürlich das ist das timing
und so weiter ich habe bei diesem
programm stina zions phänomen natürlich
an john parry denken wissen dass ich
deinen philosoph aus den usa der auch
eine philosophische radiosendung habt
ein sehr gewiefter professor ein
wichtiger philosoph der diese sehr
überraschende buch geschrieben hat
einfach liegen lassen das buch von
effektiven arbeiten durch gezieltes
nichts tun er hat auch ein blog zum
thema und sagt man sich ganz klar ich
kriege es eigentlich überhaupt nicht
gebacken
das ist unser überraschen darf der mann
sehr erfolgreich ist
dieses phänomen kennen sie das auch von
sicher schneider oder ist ja ich habe
das gelesen also es ist eigentlich exakt
meine arbeitsweise also ich habe einen
sehr vollen arbeitstag als ich fang um 6
an und hören sieben oder acht drauf und
dazwischen ist wirklich eins nach dem
anderen
dass es entweder praxis zeitungen lesen
vorträge schreiben uni vorbereiten
und da kann ich mir gar nicht leisten
mir viel zeit zu nehmen sondern ich muss
jedes immer so machen dass es
rechtzeitig fertig wird
und gleichzeitig gibt es daneben auch
diese art lockerungsübung dass ich was
anderes vorziehe was nicht schneller
fertig was nicht vorher fertig sein muss
was dein gutes dann ist das fertig und
das andere auf den letzten drücker wird
doch fertig also ist immer so eine
komische mischkalkulation und irgendwie
geht die auf wohin ging ich auch diese
also zum beispiel mein meine utopie für
ruhe wäre nicht die weniger zu arbeiten
oder doch mal ein bisschen ruhiger gehen
zu lassen also statt 14 stunden acht
stunden zu arbeiten dann brauchte ich
für die acht stunden 14 stunden und wäre
wahrscheinlich total gestresst und müde
weil alles sich dehnt das gegenteil zu
dem was ich mache wäre nichts tun das
kann nicht ausgezeichnet ist dass das
überhaupt kein problem aber wenn ich
etwas tue ist es sehr befreiend immer
das andere mit dem mit dem anderen immer
irgendwie auszuspielen und dann am
schluss doch fertig zu sein ja story of
my life also das geht mir auch genau so
und er sagt ja das beste ist dass man
immer eine priorität hat die das
dringlichste eigentlich ist weil die
macht man ja dann nicht man macht alles
andere und dass die dringlichste
priorität im grunde eben etwas ist was
gar nicht so dringend ist dann ist es
nämlich nicht so schlimm dann kann man
es noch ein bisschen vor sich
herschieben und dass man eben einen
vollen terminkalender haben soll dass
man eine volle to-do-liste haben soll
und dass die größte gefahr ist dass man
eben nur eine aufgabe hat weil dann
macht man die nämlich nicht so habe ich
meine zwanghaftigkeit zum beispiel
verloren also das ganze immer planen
listen machen aufhören jetzt muss ich
einfach dadurch und habe gar nicht mehr
die zeit zwanghaft zu sein
das ist zwanghaft minister zu machen das
jetzt biografisch noch dings also ich
war als kind und als jugendlicher extrem
zwangsneurotische also jetzt wirklich
mit aufschreiben das vorstellt
einer der sich immer alles
aufgeschrieben hat nicht nicht jetzt
diese harmlosen listen die ich jetzt
auch immer noch im iphone von christan
ich glaube ich bin auch zu machen für
europa ein aber das war schon denn das
hatte das hatte pathologische und
quellen ausmaße und und das habe ich
einfach keine zeit mehr
ich finde das interessant ich meine ich
sieht es mit zwei der kreativsten köpfe
der schweiz hier am tisch und die beiden
erzählen ob sie das noch mal sagen kann
aber der punkt ist doch sie beide zeigen
sich aus auf schieber professionelle
aufschieber fast schon
ich kenne das phänomen auch gleichzeitig
arbeite ich natürlich manchmal auch mit
leuten zusammen wo mich das machen sie
nicht nervt man hat nämlich eine
zeitpunkt ausgemacht wurde andré liefern
soll
und dann kommt da nächstes kommt auch
morgen nicht sonst kommt auch übermorgen
nichts man weiß das auch ganz genau dass
man noch wochenlang warten kann bis da
dann vielleicht endlich mal was und
hilft nur man muss so entweder gut
werden oder wenigstens behaupten so gut
zu sein dass man zur marke wird und dann
kann man sich auch leisten eine diva zu
sein das ist das einzige was es in der
eine diva war manchmal schon also wenn
sie meine die menschen fragen mit denen
ich zusammenarbeiten muss die auf meine
dinge warten müssen die ich liefern
sollte dann kann das schon sein dass
jemand findet doch die ist eine diva
aber deshalb arbeite ich vor allem auch
alleine
ich kann es mir nicht leisten also
patienten kann man nicht aufschieben die
sind dann da muss man ein kolumne müssen
zu dem termin abgegeben werden wo sie
abgegeben werden müssen
vorträge da muss man dann ja mal
erscheinen und dann muss man den vortrag
irgendwie haben auch wenn man den auf
den letzten drücker macht uni da sitzen
die studenten und dann muss ich
irgendwas erzählen das schiebe ich zwar
nicht mehr auf und schaue mich da
manchmal auch durch aber da muss ich
dann immer da sein also
das auge isst mal führen ohne meine
leiche geht da nicht so
insofern habe ich gar nicht erwähnen die
gesamte man man richtet sich das ja auch
dann ein bisschen so ein also bei mir
ist ja auch eben mit diesen diensten
protokoll wahrscheinlich natürlich dann
auch rechtzeitig aber ich habe ganz
wenige kolumne nur die ich schreibe aus
diesem grund weil das stresst mich
innerlich so stark obwohl eine wenn man
denkt dass ich innerhalb dieser arena
oder auch von anderen auftritten dass
ich innert kürzester zeit ein gedicht
schreiben dann denkt man ja also eine
kolumne es wäre doch die leichteste
übung und stück weit kann man doch auch
panik kriegen wenn man da sitzt vor
laufender kamera und man denkt es fällt
einem vielleicht nichts ein kennen darf
dann gar nicht da habe ich ja gar keine
zeit dafür dass das zu denken weil ich
muss ja zu hören und uns mit schreiben
ich habe gar keine zeit auf die
metaebene zu gehen und zu überlegen was
mache ich wenn mir nichts einfach der
perfekte job für eine aufschiebung und
natürlich was auch peter schneider sagte
es ist irgendwann auch ein job man hat
um jene es ist ein maurer muss dann halt
auch seine steine der kann auch nicht
überlegen ja wenn ich jetzt plötzlich
nicht mehr weiß wiederstein und so dass
es bei längerem projekten
das sind dann eben die sogenannten auf
aufgaben hauptaufgaben der eben wie so
ein riesenhaufen wahrscheinlich dann
erscheint da kenne ich das natürlich
auch dass ich dann herausgeber anruft
und sagt haben die anderen schon
geliefert und kann ich nicht zwei wochen
später aber da die anderen immer noch
viel später liefern als ich mache ich
dabei gar nicht so eine schlechte figur
wenn ich zb mit zwei wochen verspätung
aufsatz abliefere
dann bin ich oft noch im ersten drittel
von den von den fleißigen kommen wir
noch mal wirklich zur eigentlichen
satire zu dem was sie was sie machen was
ist gute satire für sie immer ganz platt
gefragt haben was ist gute satire
das ist eben dieser gedanke noch darüber
nicht einfach nur das schreiben was ist
nein ich das über ich dass da sind wir
wieder bei freude und der psychoanalyse
nicht nur beschreiben was ist nicht nur
nicht nur mit
carla oder am wortspiel eine pointe zu
generieren sondern noch den doppelten
boden vielleicht eine andere perspektive
reinbringen vielleicht das ganze
umdrehen und im spiegel sich anschauen
dass es für mich gute satire also es
muss irgendwo auch das herren bewegung
nicht direkt nur in den magen finde ich
finde ich auch es muss einen gedanken
haben der sagen hält der nicht seine
kritik jetzt der eigentlich gar keine
kritik ist nun oma kalauer und wenn das
noch in dem carla gelingt dann ist
einfach dann ist perfekt das heißt es
muss lustig sein
es ist lustig weil den kurzen form
natürlich gibt es auch eine tierische
filme die jetzt nicht ein dauerbrenner
sind aber die irgendwie komisch
qualitäten haben also ich rede jetzt von
sozusagen der kurzen schnellen gebrauch
satire für filmen und satirisch bücher
gilt wahrscheinlich ganz was anderes da
kommt man nicht also das erträgt man ja
kaum wenn jetzt auf jeder seite 125
kalauer sind sondern als roman wird man
das oft schwierig bleibe kolumnen oder
längeren texten wenn ich die gewohnt bin
auf der bühne satire zu machen ich muss
dann dichter herausnehmen von
komponenten weil das ganz schwierig es
zum lesen das ist gar nicht an
und dass es nicht angenehm zu lesen wenn
jedes dritte wort ein wortspiel ist oder
eine doppel deutung hat da will man auch
ein bisschen fließtext dazwischen aber
was ich was mir auffällt dass oft
heutzutage der mainstream fehlt also so
dass das das allgemeine wissen das
gemeinsame wissen dass geteilte wissen
der gesellschaft ist das ist alles viel
individualisierter geworden eben
beispielsweise heute gucken viele leute
netflix oder privatsender
es ist nicht mehr so dass jetzt alle
menschen sternstunde philosophie schon
am nächsten tag kann könnte man darüber
satire machen und alle wir uns verstehen
und versuchen sie es doch nicht
versuchen aber wenn ich dann hat eine
politisch satirische
kolumne schreibe oder eine nummer mache
auf der bühne und dann mache ich einen
körper oder irgendetwas was vielleicht
unter die gürtellinie geht aber
inhaltlich hat es mit einem politischen
phänomen oder irgendwas zu tun
dann gibt es viele leute die verstehen
dann nur den kalauer aber denn die
doppeldeutigkeit nicht oder nur wenn man
den boden gemeinsam richtung richtig und
sind dann wird mir dann manchmal
vorgeworfen ja das ist warum habe ich
primitiv und so und dann erkläre ich mal
aber das ist ja das und das und das habe
ich nicht verstanden habe ich keine
ahnung und das finde ich manchmal noch
schwierig zu spüren wo liegt denn das
allgemein müssen weil das ist
schwieriger als vor 20 und das könnte ja
auch damit zu tun haben dass sie uns
überhaupt die frage stellen müssen
welche funktionen hat ihre eigentlich
welche funktion haben
nachrichtensendungen oder überhaupt
nachrichten und welche funktion hat
satire und da gibt es ja eine
interessante debatte zurzeit das zum
teil beobachtet er behauptet wird satire
formate würden die klassischen
informationssendungen ablösen gerade bei
jungen menschen also beispielsweise
satire formate wie die late-night-show
so denken die an jan böhmermann neo
magazin royal oder auch giacobbo müller
die sind beliebt oder werden stärker
geguckt aus informationssendungen und
einer der dieses phänomen sehr genau
beobachtet ist der comedian trevor noah
bereits 2015 die tagesschau in den usa
moderierte
[Applaus]
immer mehr leute schauen jetzt kommen
weil gute satire die wahrheit zeigt
nachrichtensendungen in amerika
informieren nicht mehr
sie wollen vor allem unterhalten und
lassen leute aufeinander los aber das
ist kein journalist gute satire die
wahrheit zeigt stimmt das wahrscheinlich
hat schon was mit einer enttäuschung mit
dem infotainment zu tun also wenn man
sich vorstellt das war jetzt eine
jüngste medien erhebung das 20 minuten
das weitverbreitete organ für die
politische und gesellschaftliche bildung
ist und meinungsbildung meinungsbildung
genau dann kann man sich natürlich
fragen ist man nicht vielleicht gerade
zu auf einem bildungsbürger kanal wenn
man böhmermann oder so schaut aber
andererseits eben das entzieht sich
wechselseitig irgendwie das wasser also
so sowie partie basler gesagt hat wenn
dieser gemeinsame grund nicht da ist
dann funktioniert eben auch das ja das
ist ja eine satire über sonst hat man
immer nur sein luft aufgeblasenes zelt
wo dann auch die luft wieder bitte
schnell schnell raus ist also ich finde
es eine eher bedenkliche geschichte also
als dieser begann ich manchmal ja weil
wir da als satire können und satiriker
dann dann die arbeit des journalismus
auch noch mitmachen müssen oder
übernehmen müssen wir müssen zuerst
informieren damit wir dann darüber
satire machen können und das ist genau
das was ich beobachte ein renato kaiser
zum beispiel da macht
netz macht er so aufklärungs filmchen
und zuerst erklärt da immer das phänomen
bevor er dann die witze darüber macht
michael elsner desgleichen und eben all
diese amerikanischen und englischen late
night shows die funktionieren schon
lange so und in der schweiz wird auch
immer mir das ist so und es ist so eine
umkehrung die politik und der
journalismus aber auch die politik wird
immer mehr zur unterhaltung und da wird
immer stärker polarisiert auch und die
satire ist so dass ausreichende element
und das ist eigentlich eine umkehrung
der aufgaben und ich eben ich finde es
eher bedenklich und ich finde eben auch
dieser ganze satire haikutter dass man
die satire zu sowas staatstragende macht
und so wichtig und so also ich finde
also ich finds satire sollte nur zugabe
sein sollte irgendwie eine spitze gegen
sachen sein die andere leute vielleicht
nicht so merken und wo man dann
sozusagen mit mit schafen geschärften
blick jetzt darauf hinweist aber so
diese diese überschätzung der satire
tote satire eben auch nicht gut glaube
ich man könnte ja auch sagen wenn die
satire sowas ist wie der hofnarr einer
gesellschaft also das korrektiv das mit
läuft dann geht man immer noch davon aus
es gibt aber eine funktionierende
regierung es gibt dann könig oder soll
ich denn die an donald trump denken dann
glaube ich kenne sie alle
die satirische verzerrung von trump
diese schnell geschnitten videos wo man
in die immer gleichen plattitüden
wiederholen lässt
aber was kommt wirklich sagt wissen
viele von uns eigentlich nicht ist man
interessiert sich gar nicht so sehr
dafür
ebenso sind damals irgend tragen ja ich
glaube also zum beispiel dass man das
einem trump dann nicht viel mehr
einfällt als sie dieses bild war mit dem
stück klopapier am am schuh die treppe
hoch läuft von seiner air force one oder
die ewigen witze über seine frisur das
gibt es natürlich auch manchmal ein
bisschen moore sophisticated aber es hat
so fasst rothrist ist aber es ist aber
auch schwierig natürlich eine figur mit
traum der sich selbst schon zur
karikatur macht teilweise noch stärker
zu karikieren
das ist ja auch eine tragik also ich
finde aber man könnte zb dann satire
über diese dumme dann trump kritik
machen also das finde ich ihn erledigen
genau gegen zwar niemand das noch
verstehen scheint jede boden des
doppelten boden genau das ist das
deshalb mache ich so gerne diese instant
protokolle weil sie sind die beziehen
sich ja genau auf eine diskussion oder
ein phänomen und alle zuschauer davon
gehe ich natürlich aus haben die ganze
diskussion mit bekommen und ich mache da
nur genau über das reine satire und da
kann ich davon ausgehen wir haben alle
denselben wissensstand sie schalten
wahrscheinlich erst zum schluss bei
ihnen einen und wissen nicht nur dann
sind sie aber selber schon klar ja ja
das ist ja auch nicht lustig oder man
könnte sagen vielleicht ist auch die
aufgabe dass das bildungslücken
schmerzlich spürbar zu machen aber ich
glaube das funktioniert aber schmerzt
niemand genau wer das nicht versteht und
dann sagen wir einfach das ist lustig
man kann ja sagen es gibt ja durchaus
auch gefahren der satiren wir sind
wahrscheinlich jetzt bei einer und ich
würde weiß nicht ob die these stimmt ich
würde sagen dass ich eigentlich die
gefahr des zionismus nämlich überhaupt
nicht mehr das interesse daran zu haben
überhaupt einen aufklärungs potenzial in
der satire zu sehen sondern nur den witz
um des witzes willen zu machen
das ist das was eigentlich peter
sloterdijk gemeint hat in seiner kritik
der zynischen vernunft dass er gesagt
hat sich eine verkehrung der aufklärung
wir versuchen nicht mehr aufzuklären mit
der satire sondern es geht nur noch
darum sich überhaupt über das ansinnen
verstehen zu wollen lustig zu machen
das wäre wahrscheinlich dann das ende
der wirklichen satire oder des
potenzials der satire
es wäre traurig natürlich wenn es nur
noch ziemlich schwere manchmal ich gehe
gern dorthin muss auch weh tut aber es
soll nicht denen wehtun denen es ist
ohnehin schon weh tut dann das nützt ja
nichts was ist denn genau zionismus ich
habe ein paar postkarten mitgebracht das
ist ein projekt von einer italienischen
kampagne solo in carolina heißt die da
wurden postkarten von künstlern
gestaltet und da wurde man aufgefordert
die an matteo salvini zu schicken den
italienischen innenminister
um darauf aufmerksam zu machen wie
zynisch die flüchtlingspolitik in
italien ist man kann jetzt sagen dass
ich schlechter geschmack solche
postkarten macht man nicht zu ferien
postkarten mit menschen in
flüchtlingsbooten wo dann draufsteht
salut ida lampedusa oder romane die
salut die menschen die in diesen
flüchtlingsboot sitzen und winkel etwas
zynisch nein das hilflos das ist nicht
zynisch dass es schlechter geschmack
weil das eine hässliche schrift
[Gelächter]
ich finde wenn man was drum kritisieren
kann es wäre das zynisch ist sondern
dass es eigentlich schlecht gemacht sagt
der name ist es ist der nächstbeste
gedanke genommen das ist mir an klaus
staeck zum beispiel wenn unser junges
publikum
noch hat der der der grafiker der spd
der ebendiese diese posten hat eben auch
viele postkarten gemacht eben die bürger
die spd will euch eure villen im tessin
wegnehmen
das war so so wirklich so die
offensichtliche genossen komik also und
so in dem stil kommt mir das vor es ist
das erste was einem einfällt es oft hat
nichts nützt nichts so vielleicht nützt
da was aber ich würde jetzt eher
ästhetisch kritisieren als politisch
also ich finde das ist wilder
aktionismus aufmerksam machen und nicht
es will ja nicht selbst zu nicht sein
und deshalb ich finde das nicht zynisch
was ist den zynismus für sie zunächst
muss hat ja auch mit der haltung zu tun
zynismus ist ja dann wenn man ihm genau
diese geflüchteten egal sind und wenn
man sogar gut findet wenn man da einige
ertrinken weil dann hat man ein problem
weniger
das ist also zionismus ist ich hatte ihn
facebook bekam ich mal ein bild
zugeschickt hier ist die lösung und dann
eine bohrmaschine nebst zu einem
schlauchboot dass das ist zynisch weil
das ist nicht lösungsorientiert das ist
das ist auch böse
aber ist es wirklich so ich kann immer
weniger sagen glaube ich etwas was was
zynismus ist zb diese bohrmaschinen das
schlauchboot ist das jetzt zynisch oder
ist das nicht einfach abgrundtief gemein
und beim zynismus das heißt das ist noch
mehr als zynisch genau vielleicht ist
wirklich ja und ziemlich also ich würde
vielleicht sogar einen gewissen zynismus
rehabilitieren wollen
der der hat doch sowas von ist eines
meiner lieblings zitate von könig
gelände von sachsen oder keine ahnung
macht euren scheiß alene insofern kann
das ja auch was wenn das ganz schönes
zynismus ist irgendwas befreien das
haben zum beispiel dazu sagen der saline
ist ja nicht zynisch das ist ein
unmenschliches arschloch da in der das
wenn man das zynismus nennt ist das
schon eigentlich viel eher geadelt und
das ist jetzt wiederum hilflos wenn man
eben sagt macht euren scheiß alene dann
sagt man ich weiß auch nicht man muss
die leute einfach aus dem wasser fischen
und da gibt es kein scherz mehr oder
sonst was damit zu machen und das könnte
man auch in so vermeintlich zynischer
weise zum ausdruck bringen also auch
seine hilflosigkeit aber das heißt ja
nicht dass das die grundlage ist und
sonst halt trinken sondern eben das ist
eine frage über die kann man weder
diskutieren noch satire machen noch
sonstwas frage es auch ist es richtig
gut dass jetzt zionismus genannt wird
irgendwo werden eine gewisse empathie
und und eine menschlichkeit vorhanden
sind als als grundhaltung dann darf ja
auch mal im zynismus aufblitzen wenn es
hat ein bisschen weh tun soll damit das
aufrüttelt wenn die haltung dahinter
aber zynisch oder halt eben abgrundtief
gemein ist dann ist es nicht mehr
richtig und das ist doch irgendwo da
geht es gar nicht mehr um die
terminologie
ich glaube ich finde das phänomen des
zynismus deswegen interessant weil vor
ihm an sehr interessanten punkt waren
nämlich zu sagen wir brauchen diesen
gemeinsamen boden der information
gebrauchen auch noch das anerkennen
einer gewissen sagen wir mal autorität
um überhaupt den hofnarren auszuhalten
und und das kreative potenzial des
hofnarren nutzen zu können und in diesem
zusammenhang finde ich den zynismus oder
die könig ahlen wir zurückgehen zu
antiken philosophie schon interessant
die quasi sagen der sport aus lebens
motto dieses diese totale unabhängigkeit
als beispiel der harald schmidt da sagt
er vom sicher sein
zyniker oder ein komiker in diesem sinne
dass er keine autorität anerkennen will
man setzt dich über alles erstmal hinweg
und ich glaube da hat sich die zeit
wirklich so ein bisschen verändert weil
die satire vielleicht zu weit gegangen
ist oder fast zu viel raum plötzlich
eingenommen hatte habe ich nämlich von
jan böhmermann etwas sehr interessantes
gelesen der sagt dem foto 2 magazin dass
es wahnsinnig unpopulär zu sagen sei
dass es an gemeinsame regeln gebundene
autoritäten geben muss weil uns die
gesellschaft nämlich schlicht zerfällt
und das sagten satiriker das ist
eigentlich glaube ich dass das das ende
des zynismus sozusagen von den
satirikern her gedacht war daneben der
boden fehlt ja das ist ja wieder ähnlich
wie mit den gemeinsamen wissen weil man
muss dann auch gemeinsame regeln und
gemeinsame autoritäten irgendwo
anerkennen
um überhaupt auch gegen etwas regulieren
zu können oder eben dufner sein kann man
nur wenn da ein hof ist ja also ich bin
ja auch eher auf der antiautoritären
seite insofern gefällt mir der sport
aber es stimmt tatsächlich dass die
geschichte sich sich sich verändert hat
und dass man also zum beispiel in meiner
in meiner freizeit in der psychoanalyse
war ich extrem anti institutionell was
ich in der psychoanalyse immer noch noch
noch bin
aber institutionen haben jetzt in diesen
30 jahren in ganz anderen stellenwert
bekommen also institution vor 30 jahren
war was er mit mit vorsicht zu genießen
das weil da
damit verbindet man immer erstarrung und
sonst was und heutzutage eben verteidigt
man gewisse institutionen gegenüber
sozusagen einer eine revolution von
rechts nicht unser verteidige ich angela
merkel
das liegt an der zeit an ihrem auto herr
schneider
ich glaub mein ja eben da hängt ja auch
mit zusammen richtig general
es hängt vielleicht auch mit dem alter
zusammen dass ich zum beispiel hängt
alles starken thesen auch meinen eigenen
von früher mehr und mehr misstrauen dass
ich eben lieber das denken habe was
irgendwie offen aber auch vielleicht gar
nicht wahnsinnig originell ist während
ich früher für irgendein originelle
wendung im denken
ja nicht gerade den kleinen finger
geopfert hätte aber doch zum beispiel in
kauf genommen habe dass ich mich
manchmal fast mutwillig in sackgassen
gefahren haben also wenn wir über satire
nachdenken kann man sich auch noch
fragen funktion der satire geht es da
nicht immer auch darum zu lernen über
sich selbst zu lachen
sie haben am anfang etwas gesagt was mir
noch so ein kopf ist nämlich sie finden
humor irgendwie nicht gut was ist denn
der unterschied also jetzt bei der
satire spezifisch steuerungen über sich
selbst lachen zu können und ein humor
nicht oder ja humor ist so eine art so
eine gesetzte haltung des über dem
ganzen stehen und sich sich irgendwie
von den widrigkeiten des lebens nicht
mehr beeindrucken zu lassen
das synonym wieder zu altersweisheit ja
aber eben schon ein bisschen 30 also man
denkt wirklich mehr so an den
gutsbesitzer der humoristische über
seine felder schreitet und also
ursprünglich ist der humor galgen ruf
weiß nicht ob wirklich ursprünglich habe
das galgenhumor also man wird am montag
system bekannte links mal freut man wird
am montag zum galgen geführt und man
sagt in der scheiße die woche fängt ja
gut an
dafür braucht es im publikum was diese
überlegenheit zu zu genießen weiß und
dann kommt man für den letzten moment
noch mal groß raus aber ich finde der
humor spielt immer ein bisschen so sehr
aufs eis groß rauskommen oder sich
selbst nicht so ganz ernst nehmen dann
sitzt man so eben wie loriot auf seinem
sofa nimmt sich selbst nicht ganz ernst
aber hat diese gutsherren art ist das
nicht eine tugend sicherlich ernst zu
nehmen ist das nicht genau das was der
tiere einem auch beibringen will
also ich kenne mer humoristen und
humoristen die sich allzu ernst nehmen
als solche die sich nicht ernst nehmen
sondern auch noch eine andere frage aber
was ist eigentlich die richtige
lebenshaltung und was kann uns satire
beibringen sie sind
erziehungswissenschaftlerin frau butler
17 ja die leute auch gerne was man wo zu
sorgen ich bin
erziehungswissenschaftlerin nicht
erzieherin auch das haben
deshalb deshalb bin ich ja nicht mehr
lehrerin damit ich aber nicht mehr
erzielen muss sondern damit ich darüber
nachdenken kann wie erziehung
funktioniert und warum sie funktioniert
oder warum nicht
das ist eben glaube ich der unterschied
also darum würde ich eben das denken
über den humor stellen also betten
ich bin jetzt auch nicht der absolute
hardcore an tumor ist aber sich selbst
nicht ernst nehmen das kann ja in zwei
sachen dinge verstehen dass man eh
keinen gedanken fasst das wert ist neue
weitergedacht zu werden kann man machen
aber es jetzt nicht besonders
bewundernswert oder eben dass man bereit
ist auf eigenes denken wieder
zurückzukommen wo man noch nicht weiter
gekommen ist oder wo man zb mit
altersweisheit jetzt findet da hat man
zu vorschnell irgendein gedanken
verfasst und den hat man ins töpfchen
schlag ins kröpfchen getan und man kommt
nochmal darauf zurück und in dem sinne
nimmt man sich nicht ernst dass man
jetzt nicht sich für einen sich mit dem
alter ständig füllt den topf von
weisheit erachtet ja es ist ja auch
immer die frage was was ist humor also
ist es der humor dass ich schnell etwas
lustig finde und über dinge lachen kann
oder ist der humor der sich selbst
porten generieren kann und andere zum
lachen bringen das ist nämlich sehr oft
unterschiede ich also heute ich bin
nicht auf kinder aber offenbar ist das
so dass da männer oft schreiben nicht
sogar eine frau mit humor das heißt sie
muss über die witze lachen hier macht
und beim frauen suchen männer mit humor
und das heißt sie müssen wir zu machen
dass es offenbar so und geschlechter
ding und ich glaube ja da nicht so und
diese tender unterschiede aber es ist
sicher eine kontext frage auch also
humor
in der schweiz ist sicher etwas anderes
als humor in in einem land wo viel
existenzielle probleme da sind humor bei
uns ist sicher anders als eben genau auf
diesem auf diesem schlauchboot das wir
gesehen haben vorhin dass das ist doch
immer kontextabhängig also wir sind in
einer sehr privilegierten situation wo
wir uns überlegen können was genau als
zynismus was genau ist humor was soll
satire
das ist an sich schon ein unglaubliches
privileg dar
nachdenken zu können zu dürfen die zeit
zu haben und die muße dass sie nicht
eigentlich bei wittgenstein der gesagt
hat humor ist keine stimmung sondern
eine weltanschauung und genau das hat er
natürlich gemeint je nach situation je
nach blickwinkel je nach standpunkt hat
humor dann ein anderes andere
auswirkungen auch eine andere art die
welt zu betrachten
ja aber ich glaube eben humor hat was
sehr lokal begrenzt also lokal jetzt im
nicht im geographischen sinne was in der
zeit sehr eingeschränkt ist also wenn
ich mit zwei mikro tüten vor der migros
auf glatt als ausrutscher
ich falle hin und alles alle apfel
ziehen und sonst was rollt davon und ich
sagte dann zu den umstehenden fanden sie
mich gut also ist noch mal machen
das sind kurze moment des humors aber
das geht weder wenn wenn sich die rippen
dabei gebrochen haben noch ist es jetzt
eine so tolle aktion dass man nur darauf
hofft dass man endlich mal hinfällt und
diesen satz sagen kann es ist eine sehr
bescheidene bescheidener lustgewinn den
man daraus zieht argumentieren jetzt
schon wieder aus der sicht des
desjenigen der aktiv noch eine pointe
setzen will über eine situation die an
sich und aus lustig empfunden werden
kann
ich persönlich zum beispiel ich kann
selten lachen weil comedy-programm oder
auch bei satire die ich wirklich gut
finde
bei kabarett und so weiter also was
eigentlich mein eigener beruf ist wenn
ich da kolleginnen kollegen anschauen
das ist ganz selten dass ich lache aber
richtig lachen kann ich bei diesem ganz
archaischen situationen wo jemand gegen
eine wand läuft dass es diese slapstick
sagen die aber nicht geprobt oder
geplant sind sondern eben genau dass das
was passiert vor dem mikro oder wenn ein
kind gegen eine wand rennt da kann ich
dann also dass das lacht dann mit mir
das ist dann aber auch nicht
das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich aus dem
rückenmark und gar nicht mehr durchs
gehirn jetzt habe ich am anfang haben
gekündigt das hier über zwei tücher
sprechen wollen das sollten wir
unbedingt noch tun nämlich ein
über heidi das ist ein buch was ihnen am
herzen liegt es ja einigermaßen
überraschend mein heidi das buch was ich
habe finden sie bestimmt ganz
schrecklich weiß nicht das original ist
frau basler ich finde es nicht
schrecklich es ist ein teil der
wirkungsgeschichte und die ist
unglaublich lang also für eine schweizer
autorin aus dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
meine frau eben nur verstanden ist das
eine unglaubliche leistung seine
wirkungsgeschichte generiert zu haben
und das ist genauso ein teil davon
immerhin ist es genau so dargestellt wie
sie es beschrieben hat dann mit kurzen
haaren dunklen locken zu berichten
ich wollte auch sagen ja ja ja als kind
habe ich fast ein bisschen so ausgesehen
wie kommen sie zum heiligen das ist ja
kein witz sich hinten heidi wirklich
großartig
nein also ist es so ich als kind habe
ich wahnsinnig gerne gelesen und heidi
war wirklich das dickste buch im regal
und ich habe es immer wieder gelesen bis
ich fast auswendig konnte und meine
eltern haben immer gesagt ja wenn du du
kannst das noch 100 mal lesen aber
deshalb wirst du kriegst du kann
uni-abschluss und aber ich habe dann
genau mithalten einen uni abschluss
gemacht ich habe nämlich im
erwachsenenalter hab ich gedacht das
muss ich will irgendwie darüber was
schreiben und dass das erforschen
dann habe ich spiele kinderliteratur die
gesamte gelesen und analysiert und
gespiegelt am heidi und da sehr
interessante erkenntnisse gefunden und
von wegen besser wissen also ich bin
wahrscheinlich im moment die die beste
spieler experten die noch lebt weil die
anderen sind gerade kürzlich alle
gestorben
da kann man dann auch mal froh seine
leute sterben wir sind schön im thema
drin was ich interessant finde ist dass
sie mir gesagt haben im vorfeld heidi
ist eine erweckung geschichte und so von
wegen sich selber ernst nehmen wir
können uns ja auch fragen wie werden wir
eigentlich die leute die wir sind und
wie nehmen wir uns ernst müssen wir dazu
erweckt werden oder gibt es da zum
planen uns drin erklärungs geschichte
habe ich gesagt eine rückkehr in die
geschichte ist ja noch schlimmer so
alleine werden
tvd sein wollen sondern es braucht eine
bekehrung ja bei heidi beispiel ist das
natürlich gott sie ist der pianistin und
hat diese göttliche vorsehung auch drin
ich glaube es gibt braucht ja immer
andere die einen auf irgendwas bringen
also eben alle versuche sind ja
gescheitert kinder seien isoliert
aufwachsen zu lassen dann zu gucken ob
sie jetzt hebräisch lateinisch
griechische götter
sie sind eben alle gestorben mangels
zuwendung ja und ich glaube das ist
jetzt eigentlich triviale geschichte nur
mit der bekehrung und erweckung da hat
man natürlich jetzt mühe aber wenn man
das jetzt ein bisschen runter schraubt
auf alltägliche gibt es solche
erweckungserlebnis immer wieder es gibt
bücher die so zum zum ewigen
theoretischen bestand gehören auf den
man auch immer wieder gerne zurück kommt
und zwar nicht weil man jetzt das gibt
es ja auch so leute die die einfach
immer ihre dollar in der tasche haben
und denken kann man sich mit der klage
es gibt schon soll also die jetzt finden
also die minima morelia das ist ich
brauche nichts anderes ich gucke einfach
immer nur für jeden fall steht da
irgendwie meine weisheit drin aber es
gibt doch das jetzt meint er zum
beispiel ich habe da gar nicht so oder
ich merke wie wichtig mir zum beispiel
sprecher theorie oder austin ist weil
ich immer wieder darauf zurück komme und
fiel damit erklären kann ohne dass ich
jetzt einig gibt auch keine aus thymian
hat glaube ich also aber auf die idee
man fast einen oder ok ja auf die idee
muss man erstmal kommen oder
wahrscheinlich denn viele drauf gekommen
aber das mal auszusprechen aber das
erweckungserlebnis mit theoretisieren
genau das haben sie vorhin gesagt wir
brauchen immer auch einen sozialen
kontext um herauszufinden wer wir
eigentlich sind deswegen für sie fünf
freunde ich habe sie haben ja keinen
kein bands mitbringen können und ich
habe natürlich meinen lieblings band
mitgebracht nämlich die satirische
der fünf freunde wir müssen das ganz
kurzer vorlesen für freunde essen geh'n
frei das ist natürlich kein original
nein da habe ich erst vor kurzem von
gelesen dass es das dass es das
überhaupt gibt ist es lustig wirklich
also es geht ich finde den titel
lustiger wie den innerhalb der nicht
gesagt aber ich muss auch gestehen ich
habe nie viel freude gelesen und die
geschichte drin ist relativ langweilig
war okay also das war einfach meine welt
ich habe eben auch sehr viel gelesen
aber es war eben nicht nur ein buch
sondern es war diese ganze in brighton
welt von fünf freunden geheimnis um
abenteuer
es gab sonst noch also da konnte ich
noch immer wieder ausweiten aber
irgendwann hatte ich selbst fast nicht
wieviel benders insgesamt sind 50 hat
sich durch fünf freunde und konnten
nein nein ich war wirklich er das kind
was alleine was allein im sessel saß und
schokolade als und eben fünf freunde
aber ich habe auch aber nachts prothese
frei nicht glutenfrei aber zum beispiel
auch weil die immer gepicknickt haben
hatte ich beim lesen eben nicht nur
chance sondern auch käse tomate hatten
immer eine köchin ich habe ja auch alle
gelesen diese bände werden immer eine
köchin die ihnen das picknick eingepackt
hat das war auch so ein oberschicht
roman eigentlich
ich glaube was mich interessiert an
diesen beiden büchern und warum sie ihm
die schätzen warum ich wiederum und
ihnen darüber sprechen wollte ist
wirklich weil von dieser idee
man muss lernen über sich zu lachen sind
wir zu idee gekommen man muss sich
selber auch ernst nehmen dass es wichtig
im leben
und man kann sich ja fragen eben was
heißt dieses ernst nehmen und sie frau
basel haben mal gesagt sie sind endlich
jetzt die geworden die sie eigentlich
immer schon waren
da habe ich mich dann gefragt waren sie
denn vorher quasi verpuppt partie basler
in der making oder eben gab es da so ein
erweckungserlebnis an bekehrung erleben
nein also das ist natürlich einfach
schön das so zu sagen ja ich bin jetzt
die geworden die ich bin es ist er bei
mir wirklich der beruf der mir jetzt
viel mehr entgegenkommt dass es sind
auch ganz triviale gründe also bin
ein nachtmensch und ich kann jetzt
endlich ausschlafen aus ich muss zur
aufzeichnung von sternstunde philosophie
so frühe morgen weil der
psychoanalytiker noch zu tun und ich
kann jetzt nachts arbeiten dann wenn es
was mir wirklich liegt und ich kann eben
prokrastination meine protokolle
schreiben
es liegt mir einfach alles was ich jetzt
mache liegt mir so viel mehr als das
andere was sie vorher gemacht habe
obwohl ich das auch gerne gemacht haben
herr schneider zum schluss werden die
wir sind wie funktioniert das
funktioniert überhaupt es gibt ja zwei
extreme als die vorstellung dass man
wirklich wird der mann ist wie eben der
schmetterlinge aus der raupe also das so
seine art von natur gesetzlicher
entfaltung einer essenz ist dies immer
in einem gab daran glaube ich nicht aber
man erfindet sich ich bin zwar eher auf
der seite nicht so mit identität und
sich neu erfinden man erfindet sich
nicht jede stunde neu dass das ist schon
so dass wir eben sehr anstrengend und
ich habe von mir zum beispiel weniger
den eindruck dass ich jetzt derjenige
geworden bin der ich immer schon war
aber dass ich nicht die schlechtesten
entwicklung genommen habe es hätte
schlimmere geben können und ich entdecke
in vielem auch immer so wieder so
kinderwünsche die damals waren also zum
beispiel
man hat immer der kleine professor zu
mir gesagt also ist dann wirklich
gewohnt das war irgendwie oder manchmal
noch was viel simpleren das manchmal
kaufe ich mir im internet so kleines
spielzeug zb diese winzige lupe die
gleichzeitig noch ein fernglas ist als
kind war ich dafür gestorben
die liegt jetzt bei mir in der schublade
aber das meine ich damit also man
erfüllt sich so kinderwünsche aber
natürlich nicht eins zu eins also mein
verhältnis zur psychoanalyse sind ganz
anderes geworden aber es ist hat immer
so so gewisse rückbezug
entwicklungspsychologische sich das ist
ja lustig in zwillingsstudien wurde ja
nachgewiesen je älter die menschen
werden desto mehr gleichen sich
genetisch gleiche also im halleiner
gesehen dass du mir beginnen sie sich an
zugleich auch wenn sie getrennt
voneinander aufgewachsen sind also am
anfang ist noch die prägung durch
seltener sehr bezeichnen und je älter
man wird desto mehr erfüllt man quasi
seinen genetischen code das würde ja mit
dem fass übereinstimmen jetzt müssen wir
leider zu einem schluss kommen ich nehme
viele gedanken mit einerseits auf jeden
fall denken von den rändern her und wir
brauchen einen gemeinsamen boden über
den wir uns wieder unterhalten können
damit satire überhaupt funktioniert und
wahrscheinlich noch für einiges mehr
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch vor browser herr schneider
vielen dank
nächste woche ist bei uns der welt
bekannte politologe francis fukuyama zu
gast vor knapp 30 jahren hatte das ende
der geschichte verkündet wo stehen wir
heute
die sportart fragt nach und jetzt gleich
sehen sie einen film über johannes itten
der kunst geschichte schrieb obwohl ihn
hierzulande kaum jemand kennt ihn ist im
berner oberland aufgewachsen wurde zum
wegbereiter der weltberühmten bauhaus
schule ein filmporträt dass sie wirklich
nicht verpassen dürfen
eine gute woche im bis bald
[Musik]